-Welcome back.
We are hanging out
with Matthew McConaughey, y'all!
-Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Matthew, I was reading
the book earlier,
and I just got to say I love it
and I really do recommend it,
but I love that
it has a rhythm to it, a good --
Like, it's like...
"Just because
they threw the dart
doesn't mean that it's stuck.
Just because I've got skills
doesn't mean there is no luck."
-♪ Bum, bum, bum ♪
-Yeah. You see what I'm saying?
So what I was thinking
would be kind of fun
is if we added maybe, like,
a little music to it.
-Oh, I like that.
-Like --
Like, you can get a little..
-A little...
A little something tasty.
Syrup underneath.
-You guys wanna get tasty
with this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Kirk. Kirk.
You got a little guitar?
Like, a little something
tasty for...
[ Guitar riffing ]
♪ Just because
they threw the dart ♪
♪ Doesn't mean that it's stuck ♪
-No.
♪ And just because
I've got skills ♪
♪ Don't mean there is no luck ♪
-♪ Just because
they let you down ♪
♪ Doesn't mean
you gotta get low ♪
-♪ No, and just because
they're clumsy ♪
♪ Don't mean they got no flow ♪
-♪ Just because I'm finished
doesn't mean that I'm done ♪
-♪ No, and just because
you got the gold ♪
♪ Don't mean that you have won ♪
-Take this.
-♪ Hey ♪
♪ Just because
you can pull it off ♪
♪ Doesn't mean
that you should do it ♪
-♪ And just because you failed ♪
♪ That don't mean
that you blew it ♪
-♪ Just because
you threw shade ♪
♪ Doesn't mean
I'm out of the sun ♪
-♪ And just because
you shut me down ♪
♪ Doesn't mean I have not won ♪
-♪ Just because they can choose
doesn't mean you have a choice ♪
-♪ And just because
they don't hear you ♪
♪ Doesn't mean
you have no voice ♪
-♪ Just because I'm dirty
doesn't mean I can't get clean ♪
-♪ Well, just because
you're nice ♪
♪ Don't mean I can't get mean ♪
-♪ Just because
I'm going in circles ♪
♪ Doesn't mean that I'm dizzy ♪
-♪ And just because
I'm sitting still ♪
♪ Doesn't mean
that I'm not busy ♪
-♪ Just because you and I
are friends ♪
♪ Doesn't mean
that you can't burn me ♪
-♪ And just because
I'm stubborn ♪
♪ Well, that don't mean
that you can't turn me ♪
-♪ Now, just because
I forgive you ♪
♪ Doesn't mean
that I still trust ♪
-♪ You see, there's what you do,
there's what I do ♪
♪ And yours is not my must ♪
-♪ Just because it's fiction,
it don't mean it can't be true ♪
-♪ And just because
you want one more ♪
♪ Don't mean that you need two ♪
-♪ Just because we disagree
doesn't mean you're not right ♪
♪ And just because it's dark
doesn't mean that it's night ♪
-♪ Just because
the sun has set ♪
♪ Doesn't mean
it will not rise ♪
-Why is that?
Why is that? Why is that?
-Why? Why? Why?!
-Why?
-Because every day
is a new gift,
each one a new surprise.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Matthew McConaughey, everybody!
-Hey, hey, hey.
-"Just Because" is available
wherever books are sold.
You're the best, buddy.
We'll be right back, everybody!
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Oda-lay-hay, hey, hey, hey ♪
♪ Oda-lay-hay,
hey, hey, hey, hey ♪